a loo gear with the outdoor boys YouTube
channel I'm going to show you how to
build a one-match fire in the pouring
rain well I told you guys that I teach
you how to build a one-match fire and
even the worst condition and it looks
like we're going to get a chance to do
just that because it's starting to rain
all right let's get our jackets on you
got a real storm coming down what
happened that was pretty loud wasn't
that well talked do you think it's
raining enough let me go film the fire
all right buddy all right the key to
building a fire in the rain is having
two to three times more kindling and
tinder than you would normally use you
really cannot overdo this it's not going
to be dry so get lots and lots of it the
finer the better also you're going to
need some sort of shelter to light that
match your tinder has to be 100% dry or
it's just not going to work in wet
conditions one of my favorite tenders is
wood shavings and you can get dry wood
shavings from a wet piece of wood as
long as you can keep the rain off your
shavings in this condition however it's
just you know an uphill battle the rain
splashing around the lid the humidity so
high it's just just not working
additionally the fire pit is filling up
with water so I'm having to make sure I
get the water out of the bottom of the
fire power pit so in this situation I'm
going to use a bag of dry shaving I'm
going to slip it under the shelter I'm
going to pile up all my kindling and
fine stuff on top of it and that's a
very last-minute possible I'm going to
open up the bag and I'm going to light
the tinder inside the bag I'm not going
to take it out because it will get wet
once that bag is burned up and the
tinder is starting to ignite then I'm
going to start piling as much kindling
as I can on top of this thing I am going
to absolutely smother this fire and then
what I'm going to do is just fan it
religiously just whatever blowing or you
that's been lid do something to pump as
much oxygen in there if you can't have
dry conditions at least give that fire
loads of oxygen and what you're doing is
by piling huge amounts of kindling on
top of the fire you're making a little
bit of shelter from the rain you're
keeping the flame a little bit more
isolated from the water and you're
giving that wood more of an opportunity
to dry out but unfortunately this
smothers the fire so you have to fan it
to compensate for that lack of office
remember this isn't a sprint it's a
marathon so slow and steady wins race
don't have to do this okay just keep
piling on more wood piling on more wood
and try to make a little bit of a
shelter or by putting the logs on top
we're leaning the logs against the side
and that will help dry out the wood
before it has a chance to burn and it'll
keep the rain off the coals and it can
get really really crazy but as long as
you do this you can build a fire even in
the worst condition
[Music]
who didn't sale is going to be easy but
that's how you build a one-match fire
and even the worst condition just double
and triple amount of tinder you use
double and triple amount of kindling you
use and put a lot of elbow grease into
family milk Fanning the flames well
thanks for watching we hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see more
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every week feels
nice